le pronostic vital de la clinique
sainte-marie est largement engagée c'est
ainsi que l'administrateur judiciaire
médian thing présenté hier au tribunal
mixte de commerce de fort de france
l'exercice comptable du groupe kapa
durant la période d'observation analyse
bien sombre confirmé dans le rapport de
son confluent m miroite ce dernier
précise chiffres à l'appui que le groupe
kapa a aggravé sa situation financière
durant les quatorze mois de mission
récement judiciaire le plan de
continuation du groupe kapa sera tout de
même très largement analysés durant
toute la matinée
la deuxième partie de l'audience est
réservée aux offres des repreneurs
le représentant de la clinique saint
paul nous présente son plan de reprise
nous récupérons le personnel ainsi que
le fonds de commerce c'est à dire les
autorisations de la clinique
le taux des autorisations ces
autorisations de chirurgie autorisation
de médecine de soins de suite et
réadaptation cardiaque et autorisations
de paiement
bien que les salariés de l'apix est
marie souhaite que cette option soit
obtenue par le tribunal mixte de
commerce certains points ne semble pas
faire l'unanimité manceau ne prend pas
les locaux et part avec une partie des
salariés et avec les activités donc il
est évident que c'est un projet qui est
particulier qui s'inscrit dans une
logique du groupe st-paul à savoir de la
créature nos grands pôles d'activité de
médecine prévient martin et autres
éventuels repreneurs
le groupe docteur gestio son offre
semble être totalement différente
on a offert un prix de cession de 2
millions d'euros pour le tribunal on
s'engage reprendre l'intégralité des
salariés sauf le directeur adjoint et
aujourd'hui avec l'appui du groupe
colombine on est le groupe qui apporte
la plus de pérennité à sept reprises il
dit à tous les salariés avec le foncier
mais non on a perdu on a peur on a peur
des propositions parce qu'on pense que
c'est un deuxième capitale
quel sera donc l'option retenue par le
tribunal mixte de commerce de fort de
france
la poursuite de l'activité avec le
groupe kapa santé ou une gestion accordé
à l'un d'eux
deux repreneurs ou encore la liquidation
de la clinique sainte-marie décision
très attendue elle sera prononcée le 29
novembre prochain